welcome to sbi 2.
i want to thank you for kindly taking
time to join us today
my name is julie concrete fincham and i
am the head of screening at the stowers
institute for medical research in kansas
city missouri
it is my great pleasure today to
introduce jay unruh
he received his bachelor's of science in
biochemistry
from john brown university and a phd in
chemistry
from the university of kansas he
completed his postdoctoral studies
in the laboratory of fluorescent
dynamics at the university of
california irvine before joining the
stowers institute
as a research specialist in 2008
in 2010 jay took the role of a research
advisor
and then in 2015 became the co-head of
microscopy
and since then in 2019 he's been
promoted to
the head the co-head of a co-director of
microscopy imaging and big data
and he directs the activities for that
department
if you don't know about the stowers
institute one of our big strengths is
that we use many many uh different model
organisms
for all of our research studies one of
those being yeast
and jay is going to tell us today about
gfp complementation
screening of yeast internuclear membrane
proteome
please uh input questions
in the bottom of your screen during the
talk and we will get to those after
uh after the talk welcome jay
hi everyone um i'd like to take the
opportunity first to thank the
organizers of the meeting
and the organizers of this session um
for giving me a chance to speak here i'm
going to talk to you today about
gfp complementation methods for
screening the yeast internuclear
membrane proteome
firstly i'd like to start by
acknowledging the people who did the
work that i'm going to talk about here
today
this was a collaboration with the sue
jasperson lab
and in that lab chris moyer did
much of this work as part of her phd
project jen gardner also helped with
much of the strain construction that
you're going to see here
and jingjing chen spearheaded some of
the super resolution studies that i'm
going to talk about at the end of my
talk
within the microscopy center which is my
department
sarah smith did a lot of the the work
brian slaughter was involved in a lot of
the discussions and brainstorming
melania mclean did the immunogold
studies that were required to validate
um some of the things i'm going to talk
about zulan yu is our super resolution
expert
and he was involved in taking many of
those images that i'll show later on
and sean mckinney is an expert at
microscope automation and was involved
in doing
those aspects of this work on the
molecular biology side scott mccroskey
and dan bradford
worked on automating the strain creation
for this study which was crucial to the
study
so i'm going to start off with the
confection confession i'm not a
screening person
um and my role at the institute
is often to take traditional imaging
assays and try to find ways to make them
higher throughput
and so um we utilize automation in many
way different ways we utilize it for
yeast transformation
tissue culture transfection um automated
imaging methodologies of all sorts
um and also a really important part of
what we do is semi-automated image
analysis
and that's often a crucial bottleneck to
making
traditional imaging assays higher
throughput and the bottom line that i
want to communicate is that
screening is no longer one specific
thing there is now a continuum
of high throughput methodologies that
can be applied to almost any method or
question
and so that's our goal at the end the
stowers institute is to try to figure
out a way to facilitate
higher throughput investigations of
basic science
so today i'm going to talk to you about
the inner nuclear membrane
um and the internuclear membrane
is an interesting space because
as you can see the nuclear envelope here
is composed of two leaflets
there's an inner inner nuclear membrane
and an outer nuclear membrane
and these are one continuous membrane
sheet
and the outer nuclear membrane is
continuous with the er and so um
it can be very difficult to
biochemically separate these two things
and these two compartments are separated
by the nuclear pore complex which
i'm sure you're aware of and what's
shown here
from this very nice review from the
jasperson lab
is how integral membrane
protein cargos would be shuttled through
the nuclear pore complex by
a carrier fearing for example which
would be the standard
nuclear localization sequence mechanism
for entering the nucle
the internuclear membrane and so
little is known about how exactly
this transport pathway occurs and the
processes that control
the proteome at the internuclear
membrane but it's incredibly important
it's incredibly important because this
is where all the chromatin is
so a lot of a large amount of gene
expression regulation happens
at the internuclear membrane um also
this part of the cell
controls nuclear shape regulation and we
know that nuclear shape regulation is
often
related to aging and and cancer and
other
other um failures of this system
in the cell so control of this
transport is complex and poorly
understood i already mentioned nuclear
transport
it's unknown how much diffusion controls
what gets from here into here
and also once proteins are at the inner
nuclear membrane
how are their levels controlled it's
well known that there's an internuclear
membrane associated decay pathway
um but are there other other degradation
pathways
and how do pathways such as erad
er associated decay interact with the
inner nuclear membrane
so we want to study this in the budding
east and we use budding yeast for a
couple of
different reasons one reason is
the ease of molecular biology
examination
it's very easy to endogenously see
terminal tag
proteins at their genomic locus
in a yeast cell and this can be fully
automated and it's fast it can be done
in a few days
there's a wide variety of growth media
that can be used to select these inserts
and so this is one of the main reasons
we use budding yeast
when it comes time to do internal
tagging and i'm going to talk about that
a little bit
we can also tag those endogenously but
we have to insert an exogenous promoter
and we're going to use the cdc42
promoter which is a fairly conservative
promoter
but you should be aware that some for
the n-terminal screen
some of the lowly expressed proteins
will be overexpressed a little bit
these are not highly overexpressed
but they are certainly sometimes a
little bit more than their
endogenous counterparts
um and so we're going to screen this
internuclear membrane proteome
with a method that's often referred to
as split gfp
some people call it bi-molecular
fluorescence complementation
um and it was described in this nature
biotechnology paper
in 2005 and the basic concept is that
the gfp molecules split into two parts
and we
call the little part gfp11 the bigger
part we call gfp one to ten
and when these two pieces come together
um they become fluorescent so they're
non-fluorescent on their own and they
become fluorescent when they come
together
and they bind with relatively low
affinity to one another
so in these control examples that you
see here we're using a protein
that localizes strongly to the
nucleoplasm it isn't chromatin localized
it's in the nucleoplasm called pus one
and plus one is attached to the small
part of gfp the gfp-11 part and you can
see
we all we have in the green channel is
autofluorescent signal and in the red
head channel we have very strong nuclear
localized signal
if on the other hand we take an integral
membrane new internuclear membrane
protein asi-1 here as an example and
attach it to the larger part of gfp
the gfp-1-10 version we don't see
anything in either channel other than
the autofluorescence in the green
now when we express these together you
can see the accessibility
of this epitope at the inner nuclear
membrane
of of of these cells leads to strong
complementation of signal and now we see
very very strong signal here at the
internuclear membrane and this was
published in
a paper in jcb in 2016.
um and so we decided we wanted to screen
for what proteins were accessible at the
inner nuclear membrane
um and we we selected
a little over a thousand strains to look
as proteins to look at
um we ended up counter screening 560 in
one of those
tagged on the n-terminus and uh this
includes
all open reading frames in yeast that
are possibly transmembrane so these are
all
open reading frames that have uh
characteristic hydrophobic regions that
that look as though they might be
transmembrane and this was a pretty
intense effort this was a three to four
month effort
um it was all done with a very high
sensitivity confocal microscope this is
the microscope we use it's a complicor 3
it has
avalanche photodiodes for detection
which are incredibly sensitive
this allows us to approach single
molecule sensitivity
but the sacrifice is speed this is a
fairly low
speed um process and we did all of our
imaging
by hand and we did all the annotation by
hand as well
for this first round of screening and so
let's talk about some of the results um
so we had three basic categories of
results
we had proteins that didn't show
anything at the internuclear membrane so
clearly negative for
um at least that part of the protein at
the internuclear membrane
we had proteins that were strongly
positive for the inner nuclear membrane
and then we also had proteins that were
positive at the inside of the nucleus in
the nucleoplasm
but were soluble were you know freely
moving throughout the nucleoplasm
and this is expected because even though
we
tried to choose proteins that were
transmembrane
some of them were characterized its
transmembrane and and ended up
not being associated with the membrane
so to summarize our results we had 529
strains in our initial screen that were
negative
we had 169 that were soluble and
positive and then 312 that were
positive at the internuclear membrane
which is what we were trying to screen
for
then we did a secondary screen with
these negative
hits the c-terminus of many proteins
has signal sequences that are
responsible for localization within the
cell
and so we wanted to counter screen those
tagged at the n-terminus
and once we did that we found a hundred
more proteins
that were positive for the inner nuclear
membrane and so we have 412
proteins that are potentially at the
internuclear membrane
and given that high number we were
somewhat skeptical of those results and
we wanted to do
strong validation of these results and
the strongest way we know how to
validate is
with immunogold electron microscopy and
so you can see here
in electron microscopy you could easily
resolve both the inner and the outer
leaflet
of the of the nuclear envelope and these
black dots
are our immunogold signals and we can
quantify what percentage of those are
present at the internuclear envelope
and you can see that some of them are
quite low but many of them have
significant numbers of
immunoglobulizations that are at the
internuclear envelope so
we were able to confirm many of these
signals
another way we validated this was with
theta nuclei theta nuclei are so named
because they look like the greek symbol
theta
and these are nuclei that have a bridge
of internuclear membrane that goes
through the middle of the nucleus
and so we don't expect any outer nuclear
membrane proteins to be on this bridge
and so if we see signal on that bridge
as you can see here
we see it here and we see it here
we were able to validate the
localization of many of our signals to
the internuclear envelope
and so um we created a tool
um a website that you can access if you
want to if you go to this
link you can look up your favorite
protein
and see if it was um screened in our
screen and whether or not it was at the
inner nuclear membrane
and this is a tool for the community to
use this is showing the c terminus
viewer but there's also an n-terminus
viewer as well
so the big question we had then at that
point was why are so many proteins at
the inner nuclear membrane
um and we don't really know
um one of the things may you know
obviously the most intriguing option is
that these have novel
unknown novel functions of the
internuclear envelope
like i said before we don't really know
what role diffusion in non-specific
transport plays
but in particular we are interested in
the internuclear membrane quality
control
process and so what we did was we
did a counter screen where we deleted
different pathways of different quality
control
components within the yeast cell and saw
how that affected our internuclear
membrane localization and so
the particular one we were interested in
was asi-1 which is the internuclear
membrane associated decay pathway
some of these components are shared
between the er and the inner nuclear
membrane
but we also had components that were
unique to the er
decay and pep4 is a vacuole or decay
component so um what we did was we
started a second round of screening and
now since we want to screen so many more
proteins we wanted to try to automate
things and speed them up a little bit
so we didn't commit so much time to this
um and so part of this was
we just had to eliminate some of the
more difficult strains to grow
and to image we switched our microscope
now we're using a spinning disc
microscope with an scmos
camera scientific cmos camera this is
very sensitive
and it has a wide field of view for fast
screening
but it is not as sensitive as our first
round of screening was
and so um but but it's able to see many
of the proteins that we're looking for
we're also using where this is a nikon
microscope we're using their jobs
interface for automation
and that allows us to automate many of
the the the imaging processes
and all this together allowed us to
image 96 strains in two hours
and so all together we were able to do
all of this in less than a month of
imaging time
so a considerable speed up compared to
what we did before the other thing we've
done is we've used
automated segmentation and analysis
image analysis
and that has allowed us to very rapidly
analyze these results
and do them in a quantitative fashion um
so our results fall into
uh three basic categories one is
proteins that were not
at the internuclear membrane and
suddenly are um
and this i'm showing the example here of
asi one deletion that was that in mad
component
um a more common occurrence is a protein
that was weakly
at the inner nuclear membrane and
becomes stronger in that
in that compartment and then we had some
that um
went from basically negative or weak
soluble signal
to stronger soluble signal and we're not
going to talk about those so much
so i'm not going to go into incredible
detail on these results
but i wanted to talk about just general
trends that we saw
and one of the general trends that we
saw was that this asi-1
protein deletion um results in
a much larger proportion of proteins
increasing at the internuclear membrane
compared to some of these other
categories that we have what's
interesting though is and that makes
sense with its role
as an idmat component what's interesting
though is that all these components
affect the localization of significant
numbers of of
proteins but in addition
um there's many of the proteins at the
internuclear membrane that are not
affected by any of these pathways
so a couple of conclusions we can draw
off from that just broadcast
conclusions um the inner nuclear
membrane proteome contains a large
number of proteins
we are still not sure whether these are
functional functional or accidental
components
um but these are fully formed proteins
and so
it's likely that even if there's
accidental diffusion of these proteins
into the into the inner nuclear membrane
they may be functioning in a
non-canonical fashion once they're there
um many are unaffected by degradation
pathway mutants
so we don't know if there's other
undisclosed undiscovered pathways that
are involved
or potentially these pathways work
together in compensatory ways
that we haven't anticipated yet um and
as i said
the nmad complex results in the highest
proportion of inm
increases as expected
so i wanted to spend the end of my talk
talking about
some other fun things that we're doing
with split gfp
and so i want to start with a question
that was
that came up as we were doing this
screen um so one of the things we
noticed was at the inner nuclear
membrane
was the er transocon complex
and this is involved in inserting newly
translated peptides
into the er membrane um
and this complex has two versions it has
a version with a core of 661 and a
version with core of ssh1
um and these are both at the
internuclear membrane in high
quantities what's interesting is
these proteins form complexes with sbh1
and sss1
and in this case sph2 and sss1 and
sbh2 is
at at the internuclear membrane as you
can see here
but sbh1 is not at the internuclear
membrane and so that raised the question
as to
how this complex can potentially
function at the internuclear membrane
is sbh2 somehow substituting for sbh1 in
this complex
at the internuclear membrane so in order
to investigate this
we turn to a technique called
fluorescence cross-correlation
spectroscopy
um fossils cost cost correlation
spectroscopy
measures the noise in the
co-diffusion of labeled molecules in
order to measure the extent of
co-diffusion and so
um here as an example you could park
your confocal microscope somewhere in a
cell
and if you have green and red molecules
diffusing independently of one another
you're going to see random signals
in their diffusion traces but if you
have molecules moving together you're
going to see that these signals are
highly correlated and that allows you to
measure the extent of interaction of
these
of these proteins on the membrane we
have to do a little trick
we scan repeatedly as a function of time
and that allows us to track
the membrane here's those scans in a
kymograph form
we can track the membrane while we watch
molecules diffuse and
fluctuate on that membrane
okay so getting back to our 661 ssh1
complex
um we started by looking at the cortical
er
where we expect these to be behaving in
their canonical state
and as expected 661 has a has a high
affinity has a low
kd for sph-1
at the cortical er um conversely
um ssh1 has a low kd or a high affinity
for sph2 as expected
and when we go to the internuclear
membrane the affinity of
both of these components for sbh2 the
only component that's at the
internuclear membrane
both of these have a very high affinity
for that component
indicating that it's possible quite
possibly substituting in
where the other component is not
available at the inner nuclear membrane
another fun thing that we've been able
to do with split gfp is we've been able
to utilize it in super resolution
studies to look at
the geometry of different complexes one
example of that
is our investigations into the sun cache
complex
the sun cache proteins are known to span
the nuclear envelope
and act as as tethers for the for the
nuclear envelope and in yeast the
proteins that
do this function are mps3 and mps2
and these proteins also are involved in
stabilizing the centrosomal pore in the
nuclear envelope yeast has
a centrosome that sits in the nuclear
envelope called the spindlple body
and we wanted to understand the geometry
of this interaction and we had a
hypothesis
that um this this interaction at the c
terminus could be
added to an interaction at the end
terminus that could possibly stabilize
the curvature
of the membrane at the nuclear envelope
and so
we did super resolution um with this
this split gfp
where we put the split gfp either at
both c termini
of mps2 and mps3 or at both n termini
and we get complementation in both cases
um confirming the possibility of this um
[Music]
of this parallel um complex forming here
um the other thing that was interesting
is we also see complementation of this
at the duplicated centrosome and this
duplicated centrosome hasn't inserted
into the membrane yet
and this suggests that potentially mps2
and mps3 are involved
at the duplicated centrosome starting to
remodel the membrane in preparation for
insertion
of this new centrosome that's an
intriguing possibility that we want to
pursue further
so to conclude um gfp complementation
assays enabled our proteome screen
we saw a very large number of
transmembrane proteins at the
internuclear membrane and are still
investigating that
the quality control pathways influence
some of those localizations
and nmad clearly has a large role but
there's many also that aren't
involved we were able to use gfp
complementation for fluctuation
microscopy
spectroscopy um of internuclear membrane
interactions
um and then finally we could use gfp
complementation with super resolution
microscopy
to investigate structural components in
c2
so i'd like to thank you for your time
and mostly i want to thank
um jim and virginia's towers for their
incredible generosity
um donating a large amount of their
wealth to make this towers institute's
mission possible
and to allow me to do the collaborative
work that i'm able to do
at the stowers institute thank you
wonderful talk um if anybody has
questions please put them
into the question box at the bottom of
your screen
uh the first question that we have is
what controls or counter screen
the incorporal or the lack of
reversibility of the gfp
by visc once formed
yeah that's a really good question um so
the the best c molecule that we're using
is one i i put the reference to the
cabin two's paper
in in that slide and so if you can look
back at the slides you can go see that
um but in in particular this what gfp of
molecule is reversible
um how reversible it is um depends on
time scale
and i believe the the dissociation
constant
is in the micromolar regime and um
so so we do think that we're probably
stabilizing
by a slight amount some interactions um
but the the correlation that we see with
the nano with the immunogold
and with the theta nuclei which don't
have this interaction on them
suggests to us that we're not
dramatically influencing
the fraction of a molecule of the
internuclear membrane
the second question is is split gfp
fluorescence
retained after fixation with
formaldehyde or other cross-linking
agents
yeah that's another great question
question um
i so i don't know how thoroughly we've
tested that
i know we saw some changes upon fixation
and so we ended up doing the entire
screen
with live cells but it would be
interesting to
explore that further especially for
higher throughput screening
a third question is how do you think the
structure of the nuclear pore complex
influences the composition of the
internuclear envelope
yeah so that's a really good question so
um if covet wouldn't have happened
i would be probably talking about that
today we've been using super resolution
with split gfp
to try to understand the the structure
of the nuclear pore complex
and and so we we don't have a complete
answer to that
um but we're definitely working on tools
to more thoroughly explore the structure
of the nuclear pore complex and try to
understand
how proteins use that to access the
inner nuclear membrane and to leave the
internet
membrane i have a question for you
so since this is a reversible
complex and you can see almost at a
single
cell resolution are you able to measure
residence times
of the protein protein interactions
we haven't done that but i think that's
a great idea
um it would be really cool to look at
these
um in mad deletions and see if that
changes the residence time
um so i think that's a great idea but we
haven't done it yet
okay we have time for just a couple more
questions um how would you apply your
technology to other cell types for
example mammalian cells
yeah so the struggle we have with
mammalian cells is that um
so we have this plus one molecule that
is
nicely nucleoplasmic and um basically
has
zero concentration in the cytoplasm and
so that allows us to interrogate only
the inner nuclear membrane
and in mammalian cells that's harder to
generate um
and so we're looking at a lot of
different options for trying to
understand
what goes on in mammalian cells but it's
an area of active investigation
great um there's a question of is gfp
fluorescence reconstitution here
happens due to two proteins
co-localizing
or colloidalizing and interacting as
well
yeah so this is interaction here but the
co-localization that i talked about when
i talked about fluorescence
cross-correlation spectroscopy that was
co-localization that was actually
tripartite
co-localization so it was the
complementation of the gfp
plus co-diffusion with another another
protein
that we were looking at thank you very
much
jay i want to thank you for a wonderful
presentation and everyone for listening
take care
thank you